hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
sepsis diagnostic perspective for
clinical microbiology laboratories
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by bd
to learn more visit bd.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
kenneth s thompson clinical professor of
microbiology and immunology university
of louisville school of medicine
dr thompson you may now begin your
presentation
thank you marie
i feel privileged to have been invited
to participate in this world sepsis day
presentation
my aim
is to briefly review the incidence and
mortality of sepsis
and then move on to the detection
challenges facing microbiology
laboratories
the focus will be on concepts
perspectives and priorities
rather than a detailed technical guide
of how to perform every test
and provide a laboratory service
or whether a company aids test
or device is better than that of company
b
here is my disclosure
basics
this and the other initial slides give a
perspective of the sepsis problem
sepsis and septicemia are not the same
thing
septicemia is a non-specific term
describing the condition of a person who
is unwell and has a bloodstream
infection
sepsis goes beyond this
it is diagnosed clinically by the
presence of acute infection and new
organ dysfunction
this term as indicated by the definition
in the slide
focuses on the host response as the
major source of morbidity and mortality
it only requires that infection be
suspected not proven
this is to cover the reality
that many cases do not have confirmation
of the infection
even though the chain of events leading
to death is presumed to be triggered
by bacterial fungal viral or parasitic
pathogens
there can be many causes of sepsis
but the leading cause is bloodstream
infections
this slide provides various estimates
from the first single study spanning the
globe
as opposed to other estimates that are
based on data from multiple studies
this was a 27-year study
extending to 195 countries and
territories
it reports figures that are more than
double
previous global estimates
probably because it includes more data
from previously under-represented
low-income and middle-income countries
in which sepsis incidence and mortality
are considerably higher
annually it is estimated that there are
approximately 50 million cases of sepsis
approximately 11 million deaths
and sepsis causes approximately 20
percent of all global deaths
the encouraging news
is that incidence is decreasing around 1
annually
in nearly every location worldwide
in the u.s
sepsis is the most common cause of
hospital deaths
at an annual cost that exceeds 24
billion dollars
having looked at the estimated global
burden of sepsis the question is how
accurate are the data
firstly most data come from hospitals in
high income countries and are not
representative of low-income countries
secondly they are a variable quality
some are from electronic health records
and others are from death certificates
some hospital administrative databases
are potentially inaccurate
and may be based on non-standardized
definitions of sepsis that are used for
case reports and death certificates
in short
estimates rely on disparate data
this hampers comparability over time or
by location or even within the same
population
also most studies are restricted to
patients admitted to hospital
and exclude children
the underlying cause of illness
and assessed data for only one or a few
years
then there are multiple possible sepsis
related classification codes
bottom line is that estimates of sepsis
burden vary in quality and accuracy
before leaving the issue of estimates
there are a couple of quantitative
analytical tools for comparing data from
different populations
these are the
socio-demographic index or sdi which is
the term i will use
and the healthcare access quality index
or haq
the sdi is something to consider when
comparing populations
it ranks the population's spectrum of
development
this is based on things that can be
measured
people's incomes
their level of education
and how successfully they breed
here's what the sdi analysis tells us
the highest mortality occurs in areas
with the lowest sdi
and these low sdi locations have the
highest rate of sepsis related deaths
due to infection
high sdi locations have the highest rate
of sepsis related deaths
due to non-communicable diseases
the quality of the data
low and middle income countries are less
likely to have high quality data sources
concerning causes of death or
hospitalization or sepsis coding
healthcare access the haq is based on 32
diseases that would not be fatal if
there was an effective healthcare
infrastructure
a population's access to good healthcare
is calculated
to assign a score of 0 to 100 for each
location
what the haq tells us
is that the highest burden of sepsis is
in locations
that have the least capability to
prevent identify or treat sepsis
it certainly is nice to be able to
measure this as a number
but i really don't know how much time
and effort goes into it
i'm sure the haq is a nice term for
infectious disease professionals
especially those employed in academia to
be exposed to once in their lifetimes
i could be wrong
but i think that with much less time and
effort
you could probably get enough useful
information
about healthcare access and quality
from a 20-minute chat with a couple of
local general practitioners
some information about underlying causes
of sepsis
diarrheal disease is the most common
of all underlying causes
of sepsis cases
but not necessarily mortality
and road effect road traffic injury is
the most common underlying causative
injury
paternal disorders are the most common
non-communicable disease that is
complicated by sepsis
in particular causing septic
appendicitis
there are two age groups for pre-peak
incidence for both cases and deaths
these are children younger than five
years with diarrhoea
and older adults
when it comes to mortality the most
common underlying cause of mortality
is lower respiratory infection
treatment of sepsis is a matter of great
urgency
blood is collected as soon as possible
followed by the initiation of an
empirical that is best guess antibiotic
therapy
typically broad spectrum antibiotics are
used because the pathogen is unknown at
this time
and there are no susceptibility results
available to guide appropriate therapy
the choice of empirical therapy is
usually based on the local antibiogram
or recommended guidelines such as those
of the infectious diseases society of
america
the idsa
this therapy may include antibiotics
such as amycasine
pipracial
carbopenem
taserback dam cefeme or vancomycin
unfortunately the pathogen may be very
resistant and not covered by empirical
therapy
in which case there is a greater risk of
death
a patient with community onset sepsis
that is a positive blood culture within
two days of admission
is less likely to have a resistant
pathogen
the community onset sepsis patients
about 1 8 have a resistant gram positive
pathogen usually mrsa
rarely bre
and about 1 in 8 will have a resistant
net gram-negative pathogen
mostly a
ceftriaxone-resistant organism which
will rarely be an espl or carbopytamized
producer
that is the need for broad-spectrum
antibiotics is less for community onset
patients
giving such antibiotics to patients who
don't need them enhances broad spread
from antibiotic resistance selection
and that is an increasing concern
whether it is hospital acquired
or community onset sepsis
the infection must be treated correctly
and quickly to prevent death of the
patient and the emergence of resistance
what is needed
is better tools to predict patients at
greatest risk of a multi-drug resistant
pathogen infection
and to provide an accurate guide to
directed therapy
so let's look at how good empirical
therapy is
this slide
is from a multi-center comparison of
outcomes for inappropriate and
appropriate empirical therapy for
bloodstream infections
in patients with febrile neutropenia
not all patients in the study had sepsis
but the findings are relevant and
instructive for today's topic
results were assessed
according to adherence to prescribing to
idsa empirical therapy guidelines
and if the guidelines led to appropriate
therapy for each patient's infection
compliance for the guidelines was
achieved in 87
of
1615 bloodstream infections
even with such good compliance
24 of patients received inappropriate
that is ineffective empirical therapy
that is following guideline recommend
following guideline recommendations did
not ensure that patients received
effective antibiotics for their
infections
as antibiotic resistance increases
ineffective empirical therapy
is going to be an increasing problem
this slide shows data for five organisms
not surprisingly empirical therapy did
best for e coli infections
being appropriate 82 percent of the time
it was inappropriate in 18
of cases
that is
almost one in every five patients
for reasons
such as espl production or multi-drug
resistance
had inappropriate therapy
looking at the second organism listed
pseudomonas aeruginosa
there were 251 blood culture isolates
71 of which were multi-drug resistant
for 51
of the multi-drug resistance pseudomonas
aeruginosa
the patient received inappropriate
therapy
this is a whopping level of
inappropriate empirical therapy
especially since pseudomonas aeruginosa
is noted for being associated with high
rates of sepsis and death among
neutropenic patients
the other organisms in the slide are
there for your information only and do
not add to the points already made i
won't discuss them but it may be
pertinent information for you to have
later
when the study data were analyzed for
30-day mortality
multi-drug resistance and the organism
type were important
inappropriate empirical therapy
was associated was associated with
increased mortality
in gram negative bloodstream infections
but not so in gram positive bloodstream
infections
there were slightly more deaths with
inappropriate therapy for grand
positives but the difference was not
significant
in contrast inappropriate therapy was
associated with greater mortality
in gram negative bloodstream infections
and especially
in infections caused by pseudomonas
aeruginosa
independent risk factors
for pseudomonas
aeruginosa associated mortality was
septic shock
pneumonia
and inappropriate empirical therapy
if you look at the table even with
appropriate empirical therapy
pseudomonas was associated with higher
mortality than the other organisms
major points from this study
were that bloodstream infections by
multi-drug resistant isolates were
common
in spite of idsa guidelines patients
frequently received inappropriate
empirical therapy
and finally pseudomonas aeruginosa
bloodstream infections are very
bad
detection of pseudomonas aeruginosa in a
blood culture has high prognostic
importance
for these reasons
is vital
that our accurate susceptibility results
are reported as quickly as possible
this is a big challenge for the
microbiology laboratory
when the laboratory investigates
suspected sepsis
because of the high risk of death
it is absolutely essential
to provide the best quality of service
let's now look at the essential
diagnostic perspectives
the first perspective is diagnostic
stewardship
this term is integral to the management
of sepsis
in the future
tests should be tailored
to the treatment needs of individual
patients
we cannot do this yet
but our knowledge of sepsis and
diagnostics
is experiencing explosive growth
with advances in computational power
access to cloud services new
bioinformatics tools and new
technologies emerging
all of this will lead to dramatic
improvements in rapid laboratory testing
for the present however
the selection of appropriate tests is
done on a patient population basis
rather than the needs of the individual
patient
and blood culture remains the single
standard procedure for diagnosis of
bloodstream infections
i strongly believe
that the detection
of bloodstream infection
is one of the most important functions
of the clinical laboratory
therefore a laboratory needs to use the
best available blood culture system
you may be able to cut costs on other
tests like urine cultures
but always make sure you have the best
quality blood culture system you can get
some basics about providing a blood
culture service
speed and accuracy are essential
the shorter the turnaround time the
greater the chance of saving a patient's
life
if a blood culture comes to the lab it
must be processed immediately
when staff
start their shift
and there are positive blood cultures
and growth from cultures of other less
urgent specimens
the blood cultures are the immediate
priority
if there is something to report from a
positive blood culture
report it as soon as possible
conventional microbiology can take three
days to yield identification and
susceptibility results for directed
therapy
this is way too slow
each hour of delay in getting the
patient onto effective therapy
increases the risk of a fatal outcome
the aim
is to reduce the time to initiate
appropriate directive therapy
this is the period
of maximum vulnerability for the patient
accurate rapid tests are essential
optimum turnaround time is critical
eliminate things that may cause delays
or impair quality
it is important to monitor quality
indicators
such as turnaround times for reporting
gram stains and molecular tests
there are many many quality indicators
that are important to monitor
otherwise quality might be sliding
unnoticed to the detriment of patients
here are the essentials for the
laboratory workup
process samples immediately on arrival
positive cultures must be reported
immediately
it is vital that cultures are followed
up 24 hours a day seven days a week
is the big one
it is essential to have dedicated
microbiologists to process positive
bloods without delay
they must be able to do gram stain
reports and initiate and interpret
follow-up tests
such as identifications antibiotic
susceptibilities
resistant mechanism tests for for espl's
carbopylase producing organisms also
known as cpos
detection of the mech gene and so on
sometimes the question arises whether to
process blood cultures in-house or send
them to a central laboratory
processing in-house is ideal
but you must have every one of the
essentials at the top of this slide
otherwise use a central laboratory to
provide these essential requirements
if you use a central laboratory service
is only as good as the courier service
deliveries every two to four hours to 24
hours each day would be good
this is something that needs quality
indicator monitoring
why do blood cultures
the physician wants to know the answers
to two questions
does my patient have a bloodstream
infection and if so what do i treat with
this information is wanted quickly
if the blood culture is positive the
gram stain must be quickly done and
reported
microscopy can indicate if the pathogen
is bacteriocyte bacterial or fungal
and possibly what the organism may be
this can give the physician a clue for
therapy
ideally the gram stain results should be
followed by a direct organism
identification from the positive blood
culture by molecular or multi testing
early identification information can be
helpful to support or modify the choice
of empirical therapy
prior to susceptibility results being
available
as we are aware empirical therapy is not
always the correct therapy
so the need for rapid accurate
susceptibility information is critical
if direct identifications from the blood
culture are not possible
there will be delay until colonies from
the subcultures are available to test
and then a further delay for however
long the identification test takes
okay here's one for the advanced players
gram stain
of gram negative rods and a blood
culture
notices notice the narrowness of some of
the cells particularly in the center of
the slide
this is suggestive of the organism
possibly being pseudomonas aeruginosa
slides like this show why it is
absolutely vital to have a competent
microbiologist doing a gram stain
interpretation for a positive blood
culture
the gram stain
provides important information for the
choice of therapy
on my very best day at the bench
it would have been a stretch for me to
have made the pseudomonas call on this
one
but we do have some superb
microbiologists in this country
who can make calls like me like this
to me
it is a scandal that contribute
contributions like interpreting this
sort of gram stain as pseudomonas are
not recognized when it's time for annual
evaluations and pay raises
and incidentally
i'm confident that my wife gina could
look at this slide from 20 yards away
and say that's pseudomonas
here is another one for the advanced
players a synodobacter is gram-negative
yet in this positive blood culture is
appearing as gram-positive cock-eye
this is a distinctive feature of
pseudomonas that is sometimes seen
and can be recognized by trained
microbiologists
but not by non-microbiologists
the point in showing these two gram
stains
is to drive home that it is critical to
have proper microbiologists to do
follow-up tests and interpretations
here are some representative examples of
molecular tests that can be done on
positive blood cultures
they take about 90 minutes which is
rapid and they have high specificity
positive molecular results can be very
helpful
detecting resistance mechanisms can
eliminate consideration of certain drugs
and possibly help get the patient on
effective therapy many hours sooner than
otherwise
this can significantly reduce length of
stay save a life
improve antibiotic stewardship and save
money
the downside of current molecular tests
is their limited target ranges
and while detection of resistance genes
can reduce the possibility of the
patient receiving the wrong drug it is
not the same as a susceptibility test
which can indicate the drugs to which
the pathogen is susceptible as well as
resistant
alan jonkins
louisville's norton hospital had an
interesting experience with very gene
testing on positive blood cultures
a positive bottle from a pediatric
patient
indicated a bloodstream infection
caused by kpc producing e coli
yet in the susceptibility test the
isolate was very susceptible
and gave no hint
to end to initiate a cavapinomas test
without the molecular tests a finding of
high significance would have been missed
allen has seen this more than once and
from posts on clean micro net other
laboratories have two
in alan's case it was not a very gene
false positive result
at our lab we confirmed carbopenomas
production
by detecting carbopenem hydrolysis
and also saw a significant increase in
carbopenemics
when tested with a hundredfold higher
than standard inoculum
an inoculum that might occur in a
patient's infection
another important point about detecting
this isolate
as a carbopylase producer is that kpc is
a transmissible carbopytamize and
therefore the isolate could have been a
source of kpc transmission
the bottom line with molecular tests of
positive blood cultures is that they are
definitely worth doing as positive
results can save lives
this slide reinforces the point that
negative molecular tests can be falsely
negative which is important to remember
the table data
from a study in which the separate and
verigene assays were used to test
250 well-characterized cavapinomas
producers
the centered pca targets
are the carbopenemias family is referred
to as the big five
ndm
kpc
imp
vim and oxa48
the verigene micro array
has more targets but requires an
organism identification to detect them
the limited ranges of the two tests
meant that met both were incapable
of detecting many carbopanamas and coded
in genes
carbopenometers shown in blue are not
targets for these tests
therefore both tests missed genes
encoding sme me nmca gim and spm
carbopenomases
in addition cepheid cannot
detect genes for the
oxocarbopenemosis of a senator back
berman again
among us target genes
cepheid had problems with the emf family
it could not detect genes encoding imp-7
imp-8
imp-13 in 14
imp 18 and imp 27.
to me this problem indicates that its
target range is not the big five
but more likely should be called the big
4.5
verigene did not detect kpc or ndm genes
of morganella seratia
klebsiella variacola
hafnia providencia and salmonella
because it could not identify these
organisms
these findings are just for carbopylase
gene detection molecular tests can also
miss genes for espl's and mcs
so summing up all this molecular tests
are helpful if you get a positive result
unfortunately
their target ranges are not keeping up
with what's happening with antimicrobial
resistance
they are not stand-alone tests
before moving on to other tests
performed on positive blood cultures
what about bypassing blood cultures
altogether and using molecular tests
directly on whole blood
doing molecular tests directly on whole
blood would eliminate the delay of
waiting for a blood culture to go
positive
this is theoretically feasible with
current multiplex pcr tests for target
pathogens and resistance genes
advantages could be that unlike blood
cultures antibiotics don't interfere
with these tests
and they have the potential to be
helpful if blood cultures are negative
but
unfortunately
these tests are less sensitive and
current multiplex pcr tests on positive
blood cultures
and this makes them unreliable
t2 magnetic resonance
is more sensitive than multiplex
pcr this is pathogen-specific pcr
with miniaturized magnetic resonance
after pca after the pcr amplification
step the amplified dna is detected by
hybridization to probe enriched
superparamagnetic nanoparticles
which causes large changes in the t2
signal
and confers superior sensitivity
this technology offers great potential
but currently there is the disadvantage
of limited target ranges
t2 contests for only
five species of candida and not
including the very important spreading
treatment resistant candida aurus
similarly it can only test for five
bacterial species
and this approach does not include
antimicrobial resistance targets
the omics technologies have great
potential for the future
in-depth studies
of the classes of biochemicals listed in
this slide
will eventually help us to understand
the interplay between host and pathogen
and improve sexist sepsis
recognition
and appropriateness of antimicrobial
therapy on an individual patient basis
at this time there remain many technical
challenges to resolve
as one example in transcriptomics
the analysis of rna transcripts
dynamic changes in transcription occur
that result in a potential lack of
reproducibility and lack of
understanding of the results
in certain patient populations such as
those with neutropenia or solid organ
transplants
the sensitivity and specificity
of these types of technologies
have not been sufficiently studied to
use them as stand-alone tests
and they require great investment in
specialized equipment and high levels of
technical expertise to analyze and
interpret data
they also require standardization of
methods and bioinformatics tools
finally
going back to testing positive blood
cultures
let's look at some growth-based
technologies but not the slow
conventional tests that were in use 50
years ago and are still being used today
this slide shows two rapid technologies
that can be performed directly on
positive blood cultures
the accelerate pheno
and the ucast rest method
ras is the abbreviation for rapid
antimicrobial susceptibility tests
briefly
the pheno is an identification
antibiotic susceptibility instrument
identifications can be done by fish
technology in approximately two hours
or with a laboratory's own system
to me the susceptibility test is what
will determine the future of athena
is based on novel technology
in which cell growth is monitored
by powerful imaging technology that
compares the morphology of bacterial
cells
in the presence and absence of
antimicrobials
mics are obtained in approximately seven
hours
this is a neat concept
and the phenol is now in a number of
clinical laboratories
some laboratories use it as a reliable
standalone test
and report results without reservation
other laboratories do not have the same
comfort level
and back up phenotests
being a result with conventional tests
sometimes finding disagreement between
the pheno and conv and the conventional
results
this raises the issue
of whether early antibiotic
susceptibility results are okay to
report for serious infections
if there is uncertainty about their
accuracy
no susceptibility test is perfect
but some tests are unacceptably
error-prone
so the thing to determine is if the
accuracy of the finger is acceptable for
your laboratory
the ucas rest method
is a rapid disc diffusion susceptibility
test
in which the susceptibility plate is
inoculated with 100 to 150 microliters
of positive blood culture broth
if there is sufficient growth to measure
to measure inhibition zones the plates
can be read after four hours
if more growth is needed zones can be
read at six hours or even as late as
eight hours
there are organisms specific
interpretive criteria for each reading
time
and readings must be made within a 10
minute time frame or else it is
necessary to wait for the next reading
time
the test has been validated for aiding
drugs
against the organisms listed in the
slide to cover most commonly encountered
bloodstream infections
it's cheap
easily adapted as new drugs and
organisms are added in its range
and the ucas people are working harder
and fast at validating additional drugs
and pathogens
unlike molecular tests there is no
special equipment requirement
but for a laboratory with a total
laboratory automation system
such as the bdp structure or copan wasp
rast has the potential for automated
testing and reading
there are already papers starting to
come out about this
there are some limitations
when we looked at it a bit over a year
ago we found that some of the drug disks
were not available in the united states
at the required potencies
also
the need to measure zones within the
within the prescribed 10 minute periods
must be complied with
overall
the potential of this test is impressive
it provides the rapid and accurate
detection of resistance and
susceptibility that is urgently needed
for the main bloodstream pathogens
this test is definitely worth
considering as an addition to the work
up performed directly on the positive
blood culture
in conclusion
because blood culture remains the single
standard procedure for diagnosis of
bloodstream infections
and is likely to be for some time
what are some targets to aim for to
reduce turnaround times and improve
quality
one target is shortening the time to
blood culture positivity
in theory there is considerable scope
for this
most blood cultures incubate for at
least 10 hours before growth is detected
this time can be reduced
if the positive signal can be amplified
to make it stronger and therefore
detectable earlier
other ways to achieve faster detection
would be to enhance the sensitivity of
the detector of the blood culture system
or find a better
a better target and detection system
under optimal conditions
bacteria multiply about every 20 to 40
minutes
every time they divide
they produce a positive signal
the problem is it is a weak signal that
gets stronger with each generation of
growth
but it currently can't be detected until
10 or more hours of growth
but the positive signal is there to be
detected right from the first hour or so
what we need is better detection
technology to detect positivity earlier
this should be an achievable target
the next ones are targets your
laboratory may have already achieved
but if not
they are ones to aim for
gram stains should be done immediately
and reported without delay
identifications are best initiated
immediately rather than waiting for
colonies to grow from subcultures
molecular tests yes do them on positive
blood cultures
antimicrobial resistance is an important
driver of sepsis especially in health
care settings
rapid susceptibility results are vital
the ucas rast method can make this
possible
also combination therapy is often needed
in this age of increasing resistance
but we don't have a convenient
accurate susceptibility test to
guide combination therapy
the time has come for such testing
especially for grain negatives
i strongly believe
that all of these are essential targets
to aim for
to succeed in one of the most important
functions of the clinical microbiology
laboratory
the investigation of suspected sepsis
on that note
i thank you for your attention
and also thank gina thompson at the
university of louisville hospital
and kevin mcnabb
at new hannover regional medical center
in wilmington north carolina for the
help of the present with the preparation
of this presentation
thank you dr thompson for your
informative presentation
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what are mdr pathogens
mdr stands for multi-drug resistance
there are many
classifications of multi-drug resistance
extreme drug resistance
i go by the cdc classification
multi-drug resistance is resistance to
at least one agent from three different
antibiotic classes
okay thank you
um our next question is
do we need better guidelines for
empirical therapy
um guidelines
need updating to respond to constantly
changing antimicrobial resistance and
availability of new antimicrobials
current the current idsa guideline
for the for the bloodstream study i
presented was first published in 1997.
updated in 2002
and then updated again in 2010
this update was mainly to provide
clearer definitions of lift levels of
risk for patients
it did mention the need for kpc coverage
if the patient had previous
lee
been exposed to the organism
or the patient's hospital had a high
rate of endemicity
then the recommendation for appropriate
empirical therapy was to consider early
use of polymix and or tiger cyclame
antibiotics today that should be
considered inappropriate
okay the recommendation in that
guideline
for high-risk patients
is monotherapy with an anti-pseudomonal
beta-lactam agent such as
acaba penem or piptazo
with other agents to be added only if
there are complications such as
hypotension or pneumonia
or if any microbial resistance is
suspected or proven
vancomycin and other antigram positive
agents are not recommended as part of
the initial antibiotic regimen
that's what it was in 2010
and that's what was used in that study
that was probably i i showed you that
was published in 2020
so much has changed now there are other
carbopenomases besides kpcs there are
new agents such as
septolazine taser
inhibitor combinations fungal infections
are more common
so yes i think we need better guidelines
for empirical therapy
okay thank you next question
does clsi have a rast method for blood
cultures
the cls i have a rest method for blood
cultures or sort of
unlike the ucas test which has readings
of four six and eight hours the clsi
version must incubate for much longer
for 16 to 18 hours just like a
conventional disk diffusion test
and it's only applied to
enterobacterialis
whereas the ucas version is specific for
two enterobacterialis e coli and
klebsiella
uh plus pseudomonas aeruginosa
acetobacter staphoria strip pneumoniae
and two species of enterococcus
also the clsi version is only for six
antibiotics whereas the ucas rest test
is for 18 antibiotics
so
ucast is much more rapid and covers a
wider range of pathogens and drugs
to me
the short incubation time for the ucas
test versus the much longer incubation
for the clsi test
indicates very different mindsets
with the ucas priority being clinical
relevance and the clsi priority being
reproducibility
it seems crystal clear to me
which is the better test in the light of
risk of mortality and in sepsis
increasing every
one hour of delay
all right um our next question
is there
is there a rule said that each site on
the body
has specific
could you pathogens you say that again
yes
um is there a rule
said that each site on the body has
specific pathogens
not that i'm aware of
and if there was a rule i'm not sure the
bacteria would behave
and uh stick to it
um
nice area gonorrhea
is more specific about where you find it
most pathogens can
occur anywhere
okay
thank you
our next question
based on the methods you listed for
blood culture evaluation for sepsis
which method
do
you preferably recommend and why
i
i said at the start of the presentation
i i wasn't going to talk about uh one
method being better than another
comparing different products
uh i guess it varies from lab to lab
what's going to be the best system but
i'm not going to make a recommendation
okay thank you
our next question could you provide more
details about the ucas raft test
and accelerate phenotest
more details
uh
i think the
freno is a
neat concept
um to me
um it
we looked at it a couple of years ago
and i i didn't think it was ready for
prime time because we had
consistent problems with certain
antibiotics
i think
ceftatidaem and sepapim might have been
ones that we
didn't get answers
that
agreed with
microdilution
the rest test
more specific information
it's pretty simple you just have to be
able to read a
susceptibility test by measuring the
zone diameter
it's uh
that is an art that's not as strong
these days as it used to be and you may
have to train people how to read zones
more accurately
but i think it's a beautiful test we we
actually used it on total laboratory
automation system
and what that meant was that a positive
blood culture could be put up
immediately and then
photos of the zones were taken at
exactly four hours six hours and eight
hours
uh so that you didn't miss the reading
times
and
the photos were there for um
for experienced microbiologists to check
to be used for teaching purposes that
was very handy
i think we got something like
74 of
interpretations within six hours
100 of interpretations within
um
eight hours
um i liked it very much i thought it was
great and could save lives
um but it was very accurate
uh the only
one we had problems with i think was
erythromycin
uh
clindamycin we missed inducible
resistance sometimes with staph aureus
but for most of the other tests it was
great
um
it was irritating that we couldn't get
all the drugs that we wanted at the
right potencies
when we did the study
uh cefataxime and cephtazidine were two
of those drugs
i hope they're available now
i i like it i think it's worth doing you
if you get an if you had an early guide
to susceptibility what drug to have the
patient on that can save lives i think
it's good it's still developing this
method but it's got great potential very
excited about it
okay thank you
um our next question
how can mortality rate and sepsis be
prevented
a lot of people die
i i think we can re
we can reduce more charity
uh the rates going down
about one percent every year all over
the place i think that's because of
improved blood culture methods
um getting an earlier guide
to what drugs to treat with
that shortens the time that the patient
is
vulnerable
general generally good
infectious disease practices like
reducing
communicable diseases
especially diarrhoea
things like that are important
good infection control to stop the
spread of multi drug resistance
pathogens in closed communities like in
medical institutions
lots of things but
that's some of the main ones
and just make sure that you don't have
any
glitches in your work up of black
cultures
and make sure that when a doctor uh
issues a request for a blood culture
that that's acted on quickly
the sample gets to the lab really
quickly it's processed very quickly when
it gets to the lab
and all the other things i mentioned
like interpreting and reporting gram
stains really quickly just cut down on
delays
there's lots of quality indicators that
you can pay attention to and all of
those are going to be helpful
in
reducing the mortality
all right it looks like we have time for
one more
question um
i really appreciate the presentation it
was quite informative kindly share the
presentation slides
um share the slides
yeah i'd be happy to do that i think
leverage make them available don't they
yes
uh yes lab roots will
send out an email to everyone that has
attended or signs up
and they will get they will get access
to the slides um they will also be on
demand
um
my apologies let's
let's do one more question
um
our hospital has a surge of covered
patients blood cultures are routine for
each patient admitted
does the virus survive in blood culture
bottle broth
that's a really good question for
another reason
um
i don't know someone else could tell you
i haven't done any tests like that but
covert in a hospital
what that what what that does is you're
going to have patients in icu
for longer periods
than previously lengthy stays in icu
ventilated
um you've got short staffing
you're gonna have breakdowns and
infection control people are overworked
and what that means is that there is
increased
risk of patients getting
candidemia
and that's something that you really
need to look out for and get on very
quickly get onto very quickly so
covert might be changing things in ways
that we haven't really appreciated yet
i'd be looking out for canada
uh candid uh bloodstream infections they
may go up
as the staff get worn down and the
patients stay in there for long periods
all right
well thank you again dr thompson for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor bd for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye